what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and just like we talked
about in our last video when tickets
went on sale for Black Panther wakanda
forever today they released the official
trailer for the movie as well and wow
does this movie look like it is going to
be truly epic now of course first things
first if you are looking to get your
black panther at wakanda Forever tickets
they are on sale now so if you are
trying to secure a seat to watch that
very first showing of black panther
wakanda forever wherever you live I
would buy them now now as far as the
trailer is concerned we have a lot to
talk about of course this really dives
into Namor a little bit more and of
course we have found out who our new
black panther is and this trailer is
really focused on the actual plot of
black panther wakanda forever and that
is the war between wakanda and Namor now
right away something that they are
changing about Namor is he is not from
Atlantis well he is in the the MCU
however they don't call it Atlantis it's
going to be called telecon and it's
going to be taken from ancient Mayan and
Aztec history from The Real World it is
essentially Atlantis and his people are
essentially atlanteans they're just
trying to add some realism and some
culture to it from The Real World and
for me as somebody who has Mexican roots
on my mother's side I think that's
pretty cool now this trailer opens up
pretty similarly to the teaser trailer
that we've got before for wakanda
forever with a funeral for t'challa in
the trailer we can see Queen ramunda and
Sherry carrying the helmet of black
panther however this isn't a traditional
funeral where everybody is wearing black
as you can see everybody is wearing
white which is probably an indication
that it's more of a celebration than it
is a funeral of course they all are
mourning the loss of t'challa the Black
Panther their King but they're also
celebrating his life and what it meant
to them and how great of a person he was
and of course this is honoring Chadwick
Boseman as well now the first words that
we hear in the trailer are actually from
Namor and he says only the most broken
people can be great leaders now as he
says this we see shots of Namor himself
and of shuri and sure he is looking at a
painting of her brother the Black
Panther this heavily implies that shuri
knows that there's no Black Panther in
that it's probably going to fall upon
herself to become the New Black Panther
now keep in mind that Neymar says can be
great leaders he doesn't specifically
say King so although it's pretty much
confirmed in this trailer that shuri
will become the next Black Panther that
doesn't necessarily mean that she will
become the next king or queen of wakanda
more on that in just a bit now as Neymar
talks about only the most broken people
can be great leaders while he may be
speaking about shuri or maybe he was
even speaking about t'challa of course
he was talking about himself as well now
it doesn't show it in this trailer but
in the teaser trailer we do see a young
Namor on land and he's looking at a
house that is on fire now if Marvel is
going to somewhat stick to his origin in
the comics Namor will be part human part
mutant and part Atlantean now in the
comics his mother was the princess of
Atlantis the daughter of Emperor takor
and his father was a sea captain so I
want to say that his father dies in the
movie when he's young now this isn't
confirmed but I know there's going to be
somewhat of a tension between wakanda
and Atlantis obviously and I want to say
that the atlanteans or telecon told
Namor that it was actually the wakandans
that killed his father when I think in
the reality of this film it might have
actually been the king of telecon that
did this to his father the king probably
was upset that his daughter had a baby
with a human from the surface and might
have ordered him killed eventually at
some point in time and blamed it on the
wakandans and that could have started
the hate in namor's heart for the
wakandans now Namor is the king we see
this as he descends in the water onto
his throne he puts a spear into the
ground and it cuts to a scene where
okoyi puts her spirit to the ground as
well and we see an empty throne room of
course another reflection that wakanda's
king is dead there is no black panther
right now but the next scene is where
the war actually begins we see a large
ship on the water and there are actually
two scenes here that look like the same
scene but aren't so I don't want you to
get them confused there's one scene
where we see the people of talocon
Neymar's people climbing aboard a ship
there is also another scene where we see
soldiers taking over a ship and sort of
holding the people on the ship hostage
these are two different scenes and they
are not the same ship so let's start
with the first scene of Neymar's people
crawling on the ship in this scene we
actually see some people in scuba gear
in the water and this is sort of where
it all begins these people are going to
be searching for vibranium in an article
that came out by Entertainment Weekly we
learned that Namor is really upset with
what t'challa and wakanda did by opening
up the world to know that wakanda has
vibranium this obviously is going to
lead to people searching for vibranium
this is what these people are doing on
the ship and what they're doing in the
water they are searching the Seas off
the coast of Africa to find vibranium
this precious metal and in doing so they
are actually invading the territory of
Namor and his people so this first scene
is Namor and his people invading the
ship that is invading their Waters their
territory and these people are searching
for vibranium however the other scene
where we see soldiers on a ship holding
people hostage is very different because
this is a wakandan ship we see the
wakandan markings and Technology on the
walls and these soldiers that we see
here are most likely mercenaries guns
for hire most likely hired by somebody
who is searching for vibranium could be
another government it could be somebody
like Dr Doom either way whoever's behind
this wants vibranium but little did they
know that the Dora milaje were actually
Undercover on this ship now this is
where the war kind of begins or at least
picks up because we might be safe to
assume that wakanda and telecom have had
their beef with each other for some time
now just like in the car Comics but
these people searching for vibranium in
his oceans is kind of where it picks up
again this is where the tension really
starts to rise and this is where we see
queen raimonda and the door milage
actually visit imbaku where we hear
imbaku telling them his people do not
call him general or King they call him
kukul Khan the feather serpent God now
as he says this we actually see a shot
of Namor being born in the water we can
see the feathers on his feet and then
they show a shot of him grown up
feathers on his feet flying in the air
with wakanda in the background then we
hear umbaku say killing him will risk
Eternal War so this tells us that not
only is Namor the king of Atlantis slash
Telecom but he is worshiped as their God
not just their King but their God now
cool cool Khan is actually an ancient
Mexican Pantheon a deity one of the
major deities so this is coming straight
from ancient Mexican history here which
I love now umbaku says killing him will
risk Eternal War because if they kill
the the god of telecon of course taliken
will forever try to kill everybody in
wakanda to seek revenge on them for
killing their God which puts them in
quite the Dilemma because clearly Namor
is attacking wakanda we hear shuri say
he's coming for the surface world and in
this scene we see Queen raimonda and we
actually see Riri Williams in the
background in the throne room they are
looking out the window and if you notice
in the reflection of the window is name
or flying right in front of it and it
looks like he's about to take a spear
and shove it right through the window
breaking the glass breaking into the
throne room maybe even attacking Queen
raimonda now from here in the trailer we
actually see Namor on land talking to
Queen raimonda and I'm assuming that
this is one of two things happening one
it's Namor coming to the surface to kind
of say sorry to Quinn ramunda for the
death of t'challa their King and her son
or two he is coming on Surface to warn
her and express that he is extremely
upset that wakanda has let the world
know about vibranium and now people are
invading his seas and most likely
telling her that he won wants her to
shut off wakanda and vibranium to the
world to where nobody can even get close
which obviously I don't think she was
going to do this was the wish of her son
and the former king of wakanda t'challa
so I don't think she's going to go back
on what he did when he was alive and
that is also where the conflict is going
to escalate as well Namor issues of
warning but Rwanda says no now from here
we get a bunch of shots of what is going
to be the war between telekin and
wakanda and from here we get some really
cool scenes one we get our first look at
Riri Williams's Iron Heart In Action we
see her very first Iron Heart suit in a
couple of scenes we see her flying over
a car and a motorcycle we see her
tinkering with some gear to make her
suit and then we see her suit launch
into the sky and we even get a hood view
of her saying let's go and this is very
similar to the Views that we saw of Iron
Man when he would be in the suit now we
see wakanda being flooded of course this
is the doing of Namor he is attacked
wakanda the war has begun and in the
background you may notice the chanting
of wakanda forever we get an amazing
scene of Namor striding through the air
just flying through the air on his way
to attack wakanda and I must say I
really like how they did this he flies
but he kind of runs as he flies and it
looks really really cool but they've
also showed us that he can in fact hover
in the air he can use his wings to kind
of Glide to kind of stay in place he
doesn't have to be in full motion
running to fly but when he does and he
wants to move fast he kind of runs
through the sky and it looks pretty dang
cool now of course to top it all off
queen raimonda says now is our time to
strike and then she says show them who
we are and as she says this we see shuri
in a flooded throne room that is on fire
but then we see Sherry emerge as the New
Black Panther now we pretty much knew
that shuri was going to be the New Black
Panther this does happen in the comics
and of course since it was her brother
who was the black panther before it only
makes sense for her to take up the
mantle after him we see her fall from
the sky and hit the ground and we can
actually see the suit absorb the energy
and this is actually technology that
shuri herself designed now when she hits
the ground and we see the suit it is
very clear that this is shuri the figure
of this new black panther matches
Sherry's figure perfectly leaving no
room to doubt who the New Black Panther
is however like I mentioned in the
beginning of the video this does not
mean that shuri is the new Queen Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios
recently told us that the reason they
did not recast t'challa was because it
was too soon meaning one day it won't be
too soon and they could recast t'challa
and or a new black panther now there
have been some rumors going around for a
while that shuri would indeed be the New
Black Panther however she would not be
the new king and there have been some
conflicting reports about this but some
people say that umbaku could be the next
king however he won't be the New Black
Panther that's what shuri will be so I
think they're going to leave the future
pretty open at the end of this movie
open for another black panther to come
in because clearly Sherry is going to be
a black panther in this film but overall
this movie looks pretty dang amazing and
I'm really really excited for this one
of course it's the next Marvel movie
that we're going to be getting that's
hitting theaters November 11th like the
trailer said tickets are on sale now so
be sure to grab them and of course let
me know what you think about this new
black panther wakanda forever official
trailer don't forget to give the video a
like And subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest Marvel news for
live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof